تروج البنوك في كثير من الدول للتعريف
الصوتي كطريقه امنه لتسجيل الدخول الى
حسابك لكن
فمتانه من الممكن خداع مثل هذه الانظمه
باصوات يتم انشاؤها بواسطه الذكاء
الاصطناعي في تجربه رصدها موقع فايروس
اتصل احدهم بختل خدمه الاليل المصرف الذي
يتعامل معه واستخدم برنامجا لتقليد
واستنساخ الاصوات بالذكاء الاصطناعي
وبالفعل تمكن من الوصول الى معلومات
الحساب بما في ذلك الانصده وقائمه
المعاملات والتحويلات الاخيره وبالتالي
اعتبر صاحب التجربه فكره الامن السيبراني
الخاصه بالاصوات ضعيفه جدا خاصه انه
استخدم برنامجا مجانيا لتقليد الاص
[موسيقى]
وات
من الكويت ينضم الى المستشار في ان
تكنولوجيا المعلومات والتحول الرقمي رولا
ابي نجم رونا اهلا بك يسعد صباحك كان
اعتماد ذكاء او اعتماد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي على ذاك الاصطناعي وصل بها الى
تقليد صوت المستخدم واعاده صوت بالرسائل
ما مدى خطوره هكذا تقنيه اليوم نسخ
الاصوات صباح الخير
لكل المشاهدين بطبيعه الحال اكبر
انه في اغلب البنوك بعد الاحاديث هلا
بتعتمد على بصمه الصوت لتعريف وتاكيد هويه
المستخدم وهذا الموضوع يعني حضرتك ذكرتي
بالمقدمه انه الشركه قالت انه انا بدي امن
الحمايه عبر انه التسجيل عده جمل صوتيه
تاكد هذا الموضوع للمستخدم بينما شفنا قبل
شركه مايكروسوفت اعلنت عن برنامج بخلال
ثلاث ثواني بس اذا انا سجلت لك صوتي لمده
ثلاث ثواني بقدر اكتب مقاطع ومقاطع وجمل
بكثير كبيره وبتكون بصوتك وبكون عم بقلد
صوتك فهذا الموضوع اكيد عنده خطوره كتير
كبيره وراح يقسم بشكل كثير سلبي على الامن
السيبراني طيب اليوم حتى لا نعيش بفكره
ضلاميه حتى لا نعيش بفكره ظلاميه اكيد
دائما في التكنولوجيا في لها فوائد وبدنا
نعرف ليش طوروها بالاساس فبالتالي هل يمكن
الحديث عن فائده ما من استخدام هذه
التقنيه يعني توظيف صوت طبق الاصل لنا في
شيء ما في تعامل معين
موضوع تزييف الصوت كمان موجود هن اللي عم
يجربوا الشركات اذا بدك يقدموا خدمات
يعني بكل بساطه هي شو الفكره انت اذا
دقيتي له انا ماني قادر رد في عندي
هلا بدل ما ابعث لك
يبينوا كانه حدا عم يحكي معك كان انا عم
بحكي
هذا اول نقطه والنقطه الثانيه انه الذكاء
الاصطناعي هذا بخلي انه انا عدت مسج حطن
وحافظهم بقلب هذا السيستم ويصير الذكاء
الاصطناعي يعمل هو جنريت لمثله
نفس الشخص بنفس الطريقه يبين انه هذا
السيستم طيب التقنيه تسمح بنسخ الصوت لجمل
محدده رسائل قصيره معينه للرد بها بصوت
المستخدم الى اي مدى هذا يقلل من خطوره
هذه التقنيه
ما راح يقلل من خطرتها بطبيعه الحال لانه
منرجع نقول هلا
هيدي الخدمه اللي بيقدموها هلا سامسونج
النقطه اللي فيها انه بس ترد عليك راح
يقول لك انه انا الذكاء الاصطناعي عم برد
عليك بمشي الشخص صهيب محل معين المفروض
تخفف من خطوره انه هي عم بتعالف انه مشروع
الشخص
بس بنفس الوقت طبيعه عم تحفظ رسايل هو
الشخص عم يكتبها كيف عم تقلد له صوته ممكن
بمحل معين الشخص الثاني يكون عم يسجلهم
يستفيد منهم بقشره ثانيه بس خليني انا
افهم في حال مثلا صار في ازمه ما مشكله
لانه ممكن يتم استخدام ذلك بتصريحاتنا
السياسيين ويصير فيها ازمات دبلوماسيه بين
دول اليوم هل يمكن للامن السيبراني ان
يتحرى بشكل دقيق لان هذا الصوت هو صوت
حقيقي بشري ام صوت ذكاء اصطناعي
هو بيقدر صحيح بس بيقدر بدي اساليب تقنيه
كتير كبيره ومش اي شخص يعني الشخص متل ما
حد تذكرتي مش بس عم نحكي موضوع الصوت
سمعنا كتير
اي تقليد مش بس
ميه بالميه شكله صوره ويكون انا اصلا مش
موجود شفنا الدي جيتها حط بحفله معينه
غنيه لامين ام معموله كلها عبر الذكاء
الاصطناعي يعني رحل لمنصه الذكاء الصناعي
طلب منه يعمل له تاكس لغنيه على ستايل
وراح على محل ثاني قال لها حطيلي هذا
التاكسي بغنيه بصوت وطلعت الغنيه بالحفله
وكلها
عالمغني بينما هو بس عم يقتنع بالذكاء
الاصطناعي
ودائما الحديث تتمه يعني في هذه المواضيع
شكرا جزيلا لك رونو ابي نجم المستشار في
امن وتكنولوجيا المعلومات والتحول الرقم